earlier this week we told you about a
rap problem reported at acacia park in
henderson after we reported that bait
control boxes would be placed out there
we had rat rescue groups reach out to us
concerned about them as victoria saha
reports these groups say there are
solutions to remove these critters and
keep them alive
although many people are scared of the
rats that they come across in public
rescue groups don't want you to hurt
them instead relocate them
megan harrington has around 30 pet rats
i was five years old and my mom took me
to that store and they had rats and i
took one in or took two in and then i
grew to four
and then eight now i've got all these
she's the owner of desert rose rottery
dedicated to rescuing and breeding rats
a lot of people would much rather kill
them and have them not exist than to
understand them and understand that
they're loving and caring which is why
the idea of bait trapping wild rats and
valley parks or at your home isn't
sitting well with her with bait it will
poison them and they'll suffer it will
cause so much pain to them and it's not
fair harrington says a better way to
solve the wild rat issue is with a metal
cage that would catch them and release
them in another area sometimes it could
be hard to tell the difference between a
wild rat and a domestic one the color
that she has is what you would see in a
wild rat but she has these markings to
be able to tell that she's not
harrington does not take in wild rats
due to diseases they carry but
recommends if you do come across them
they're more scared of you so just leave
them alone
unless you are harassing them
then they will use self defense
if you have a pet rat that you can't
take care of anymore harrington says
letting them outside should not be an
option because that's where other wild
rats can interact with them and give
them deadly diseases instead there's so
many local rat rescue groups willing to
take them in just like hers victoria
zaha 8 news now
she's trying to make him seem all cute
right
according to harrington she does
separate the male and female rodents as
they can start mating immediately when
put together and one litter can be
upwards of a dozen rats we did reach out
to the city of henderson to see if its
bait trapping worked in acacia park and
are awaiting that response denis